un atropello múltiple frente a un
albergue para migrantes en Brownsville
Texas acabó con la vida de al menos
siete personas que estaban en una parada
de autobús e hidio a varios más la
mayoría de los fallecidos serían
migrantes venezolanos
el asesino venía en el carro señalándolo
insultándonos las cosas como
la policía detuvo el conductor del
vehículo y alega estar investigando si
la mortal embestida fue intencional o un
accidente Pese a que no es la primera
vez que los migrantes latinos son
violentados en la localidad he escuchado
muchas cosas de racismo en este lugar en
este pueblo también porque yo soy de
México pero también a mí verdad me han
pasado cosas bien feas Texas sufrió un
fin de semana trágico el sábado ocho
personas fueron asesinadas en un tiroteo
masivo en un centro comercial la policía
Investiga los vínculos del tirador que
también murió durante la balacera con la
ideología de la supremacía blanca por su
parte el presidente Joe biden recordó
que las últimas dos décadas más menores
de edad han muerto por armas de fuego
que policías en servicio y militares en
activo la violencia Armada en este país
es una epidemia y es una vergüenza
internacional un repunte de violencia
con tintes racistas y xenófobos en el
principal paso de la migración
centroamericana cuando faltan pocos días
para que expire el título 42